hurting you and i'm just so glad that
you're alive and i think we should just
focus on that
and i dropped the case
and i paid for the guy's car
and a few months later jenny and i went
to city hall and we got married
i still didn't believe in the idea of
marriage and i still don't
but i believed in her and i'd given up
on the idea of being right
[Applause]
uh
one of my dreams is to be profiled by
npr i i just love you know what i mean i
think if we're being honest
i think everybody has that dream where
you want them to come to your apartment
and be like pete holmes is surprisingly
messy for a genius you know what i mean
tuna cans discarded everywhere and you
kind of hear me talking
they're talking to me why not comedy i
want to be a show
guys i want to be a show i'm just joking
um i gotta be honest uh i'm just happy
to be out tonight and take a break from
all the facebookery
can we just talk about i have a theory
about facebook in myspace though i don't
want to tell you i think this is right i
think that the government
made facebook and i think they made
myspace i think this is true i think
they made it to make privacy uncool i
really i think that's true because they
don't have to tap our phones
or survey us
when we yield to them
everything just on our own pretty well
just like yeah home address
[Music]
phone number call me
photos of everyone everyone i know yeah
let me tag those for you
that's andrew he's suspicious
we just give it all up i think we're
gonna get to the point where
criminals are just going to be on their
phones just like hey the deal's about to
go down
tweet that's going to happen
anthony the squid bring your crowbar
what's going to
happen i do like it though right now my
my facebook status says pete is telling
jokes you know but uh
i think we all have those all those
friends on facebook that kind of abuse
the status system you know what i mean
and update their status like 45 times an
hour
asinine stuff like ryan is eating a
trisket
[Applause]
ryan is taking a bath like you shouldn't
have the computer by only one
i
sometimes they have too much info too
i'm not making this one up by someone
that said adam
is sad
and not sure if he's gonna make it
through the night
that's real
somebody put their cry for help
on facebook
i didn't know what to do i poked
[Applause]
them a ninja
now
i did i did get a i did get a ninja
invite recently
i don't know why we love ninjas in this
country can we what is this obsession
with what is a ninja really it's just an
asian burglar right
[Applause]
we're saying we have them in this
country too they're called [__]
someone dressed in all black breaks into
your house and kills something it's like
oh my god
he was from japan cool
it's asking something on youtube
i uh
i'm not a cool person i don't know if
that if that's reading
are you guys getting that
not cool i'm not i'm not cool it's okay
i'm kind of like i'm 29 i don't have any
kids but i'm already kind of like a fun
dad does that make sense like i already
think the like corny embarrassing things
your dad thinks are funny
are funny like you guys are all having a
sleepover and i keep embarrassing you
like hey you can have whatever you need
like
yeah get out of here coming in with tuna
melts damn style like if you like it
then you should have put some cheese on
it you know
[Music]
out of here
get out of here okay i'll be watching
wheel here
i don't mind being fun man though
i'm an old soul now i embrace it at a
kid's birthday party i'll shake his hand
and slip him 20 dollars fun day
enjoy your day
on a fishing trip i'll let a kid try
beer like i'd rather you do it with me
[Music]
fun
you got to be careful though there's a
thin line between fun dad and creepy
uncle
[Music]
it's not really a line as much as it's a
blonde mustache
what could they decide that that was the
uniform like you like something messed
up sexually
let the world know stop stop shaving
here you fair-haired monster
i don't write the rules if you have a
friend with a blonde mustache he wants
to touch you
i am a fun dad but i don't have any hits
i i think people romanticize
what it's like to like to be a child can
we talk about this i recently saw a 50
year old woman talking to a 10 year old
boy she was just glowing she's like oh
yes
yeah oh yeah oh dad i'd love to be ted
be you b10 oh start over be svelte and
swift i bet you're swift yeah you see
color and smell things
again don't want to be ted being a kid
sucks you just don't remember this is
what it is to be ten it's not words it's
just a noise this is the sound of being
ted
you probably haven't heard that noise in
a long time because you have no need for
it as an adult but as a kid it's all you
have
it's not
i'm not sure what to do with your arms
you're still kind of new with your arms
like is this
right mittens attached to your jacket
because you're a stupid person
actively trying trying not to poop your
pants you know what i mean it wasn't
that long ago that you're allowed to
just let it rip
it sucks i saw a kid walking with his
dad trying to keep up with his pathetic
little legs right dad is walking a car
length ahead of him which is a dick move
and he passed behind him just going dad
dad i dropped my hat
god
damn my god i lost it
dad not even turning all the way around
just the half shoulder going
bradley
bradley it's gone bradley
your hat is gone leave it
that's all you can come back
you've lost the debate
screw that nobody talks to me that way
i'm a crone asked me if you talk to me
that way i punch you in the heart do you
get it
i have cash on me right now cash i lose
a hat i'll go buy two wear one like a
crown throw the other one to the street
this kid can't reason with this giant
who doesn't give a crap
that's all he can do i saw a different
kid different kids same noise following
his dad going dad
[Music]
dad i'm hungry
my dad just goes
chill it
you just had a banana
i can't just
that's his rebuttal
he wants to be like father why are you
speaking to me this way i mean constant
nutrition that i might grow oblong and
weird when all that comes out
screw that i'm an adult if i'm even a
little hungry i'll go to a freaking car
valve just eat a nibble of an ice cream
cake smear the rest of my face like a
geisha throw in the
remainder you understand i write my own
rules
at night do you get it i wear a bathrobe
for a month in public no one's going to
tell me not to i'll get a beard of bees
live bees i'll grow my fingernails till
they curl up like a water hose nobody's
i can do whatever i want meanwhile some
kids like
for jeopardy
i can rent a car do you understand
this show 50 enterprise i can rent a car
give them the money they'll give me the
keys like here you go grown-up thanks
grown-up
i'll get the insurance i'll take a crap
from the passenger seat drive into the
river and swim to the shore
meanwhile the kid's like can i go to the
bathroom
i just took a dump in a rented chevy
cobalt do you understand it's better to
be a grown-up
[Applause]
look at these [__]
you're nice
greatest people in the world
all right guys thank you for uh
listening to that who's next sean
john one of my favorites guys
[Applause]